hey Vsauce Michael here and I just got
back from VidCon the entire convention
was incredible but the whole time I was
there I thought a lot about video we all
watch video and many of us work with
video but what is it I mean what really
is video well guess what today we're
gonna take a look to begin I think we
should start all the way down at the
bottom with language what is the word
record mean the story behind the word
record is actually quite cool and makes
me a little sentimental the word record
comes from the Latin where re means
again and cor means the heart or the
soul so when you record something you
are literally bringing it back into your
heart bringing it back into your soul
remembering it now that sounds really
nice and pretty but it actually had more
to do with the fact that ancient people
thought that the heart was where we
stored memories not the brain the reason
a sequence of still images can appear to
be moving is an effect known as beta
movement if images move fast enough our
brain can't comprehend them as separate
images and the illusion of motion is
created now for a very long time we
recorded moving images on photographic
film but later on a new way of capturing
moving images came about and it was
called video video comes from a latin
for IC and rather than is preserving a
moving image chemically on celluloid
photographic film stock video is an
electronic representation of the moving
image now in the real world stuff just
happens that things just continuously
happen but in the world of a camera
whether it's film or a video camera it's
almost always in the form of frame rates
pictures of the world taken at a certain
speed that are then quickly gone through
producing through beta movement the
illusion of movement when a camera
records at a lower frame rate playback
often looks jittery and skips like this
more frames per second means that more
information is taken every second
leading to more fluidity but that leads
to a whole can of worms which is a great
transition to a conversation I had with
Dylan from householdhacker at VidCon
roll the tape right outside its Dillon
from householdhacker hey what's going on
everyone you know I got a good question
for you based on frame rates and whatnot
what would you say the human eye sees as
a frame rate very good question what
frame rate do we see the world in with
our eyeballs I mean how fast is
information travel from our eye to our
brain it obviously can't be too low
because fast objects don't look like
they're skipping they look pretty fluid
well it's a little bit of a trick
question because our eyes are not
cameras instead they track onto objects
and receive a continuous flow of photons
onto the retina sending information via
a chemical reaction to the brain now
here's what we do know the visual cortex
in our brain usually holds that
information from our retina for about a
fifteenth of a second so if an animation
moves at 15 frames a second or faster
it's gonna look nice and fluid but if
it's lower than 15 frames a second our
brains not fooled by the beta movement
and it'll look like it's skipping so
basically the faster the frame rate the
better everything's gonna look in the
end here's the thing if frame rates get
higher and higher you wind up with an
image that can actually cause headaches
when people watch it on the screen here
I'll explain white hold this camera for
a second oh yeah so back to the point
about our eyes tracking onto objects if
I do this move my hand in front of my
face and track it with my eyes I can see
my hand it makes sense but at a certain
point my hand will move so fast that
it's just a blur and the reason it's a
blur is because my eye can only track so
fast and when objects move faster than
our eyeballs can track your brain adds
in motion blur that way we get a sense
of movement happening but we don't see
something like
and randomly appearing all over the
place but this becomes a problem with
new High Definition programs on big
televisions because some of those
programs are brought to your TV at frame
rates as high as a thousand frames a
second and objects like a tennis ball
that normally travels so fast our eyes
can't track them and they look blurry
don't look blurry because the camera is
able to see them clearly and when you
watch that program on TV you can
actually get a headache or get dizzy so
they're having to find ways to add blur
back into HD pictures pretty neat right
that's great information how did you
even learn this you know I'm here for
man all right thank you you know the
bathroom you know I heard you come out
did you wash your hands yeah so there
you go some cool facts about video that
I learned while I was flying to and from
VidCon from New York to LA it was a long
flight but I learned a lot and I want to
end with some numbers about YouTube
specifically YouTube hosts videos from
all over the world massive massive
amounts in fact every minute of the day
people are uploading video to YouTube
and if you were to take all the video
uploaded to YouTube at any given minute
all together it would equal 48 hours
that's right two full days of video are
uploaded to YouTube every single minute
you guys are part of something gigantic
all right now later this week I'll have
a new episode of IMG and soon enough
we'll have episodes of dong loot it's
gonna be super cool so be sure you're
subscribe so you don't miss anything and
as always thanks for watching
they're not they're not the same person
they're supposed to be the Tribune I
lived in Chicago for four years oh yeah